[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: Welcome,
everyone, to Talks at Google.
Today, it's my pleasure to
introduce John McConnell.
John McConnell served
more than 10 years
on the White House staff
as a senior speechwriter
for President George W. Bush
and Vice President Dick Cheney.
He was part of the three-person
team responsible for all
of the 43rd president's
major addresses,
including the speech to the
joint session of Congress
after September 11 and four
State of the Union messages.
John is a former resident
fellow at Harvard's Institute
of Politics in the John F.
Kennedy School of Government.
He is a trustee
of Wayland Academy
and serves as Chairman of
the Selection Committee
for the annual Gerald
R. Ford Journalism
Prize for Distinguished
Reporting on the Presidency.
A lifelong political
enthusiast, John
was a page in the
United States Senate
under the sponsorship of
Senator William Proxmire.
He grew up in
Bayfield, Wisconsin,
and is a graduate of Wayland
Academy, Carleton College,
and Yale Law School.
So it's great to
have you here, John.
JOHN MCCONNELL: Thank you.
Glad to be here.
SPEAKER 1: Maybe you
can start telling us
a little bit about
your background
and how you started
working for the president.
JOHN MCCONNELL: Sure.
The best way to go to work for
a president as a speechwriter
is to go to work for a
governor as a speechwriter,
and make sure that that
governor gets elected president.
It's as simple as that.
I was very fortunate to go to
work for George W. Bush down
in Austin, Texas, right at the
beginning of the year 2000,
right as his
presidential campaign was
getting into full gear.
He had two speechwriters
on the team there
already, Mike Gerson
and Matthew Scully.
And I had known both
of them previously,
and we joined together
as the speechwriting team
there at the beginning of 2000.
Saw through the entire campaign
of the closest election
in American history, the
historic recount in Florida,
and then the short presidential
transition between Clinton
and Bush.
Pretty much half the normal
length because of the--
because of all the
litigation in the recount.
And then started at the White
House on January 20, 2001.
And in my case, stayed
until the last day.
Mike and Matthew both
moved on sometime prior
to the conclusion.
But I stayed the full time.
Prior to that, I had
worked at the White House
for a couple of years
for Vice President Dan
Quayle in the early '90s.
And that was really my first
speechwriting experience.
And then in the
interim, I had worked
for former Vice President
Quayle after he left office
for several years.
And I also wrote speeches for
Bob Dole in the 1996 campaign.
Traveled around the country
with Bob Dole for the last six
months of the losing campaign
against President Clinton
in '96.
So 2000 was the first winning
campaign I'd ever been on.
SPEAKER 1: And
from your intro, we
saw that you served both as
speechwriter to the president
and the vice president.
Is that something that's common?
JOHN MCCONNELL: It's
not, as far as I know.
And I was told that
there had never been,
in the history of the
White House, someone
whose title was speechwriter
to the president and vice
president.
I was a special
assistant, and later,
a deputy assistant
to the president,
but also an assistant
to the vice president.
So I had an official
title in both offices.
And the story there
was that I just
got to know Dick Cheney
during the 2000 campaign,
and my colleague
Matthew Scully and I
had done some speeches for
him, including his acceptance
speech.
And at the time
of the transition,
he said he would like me to
be his principal speechwriter.
And I said, well, I
will gladly do that.
Got along very well with him.
I said, but of course,
I'm going to keep
writing for the president.
And he said, oh, yeah.
There's going to be
a complete seamless--
seamless arrangement between the
president and vice president,
not just in speechwriting
but in other fields as well.
So I don't think they
have done it that way.
I don't think Obama and
Biden did it that way.
I doubt that Trump and
Pence do it that way.
There's such great
difference between the two.
But I honestly don't know.
But that, as I say, was to
my knowledge the first time.
So I was always able, during
that whole eight years--
and nine if you include
the 2000 campaign--
to really be involved in
both presidential and vice
presidential speeches
at all times, which
was fun, interesting.
Kept me very busy.
But also, just found myself
working for not just one,
but two people that
I really liked.
SPEAKER 1: So what does a
speechwriter at the White House
actually do?
Maybe you can walk us
through your day-to-day.
JOHN MCCONNELL: Yeah.
It's a little bit hard
to plan your life.
I learned that
early on when you're
a speechwriter at
the White House.
Or actually I should say,
it's not hard to plan.
You can plan all you want.
[LAUGH]
It's easy.
Just sit down.
Here's my week.
It's planned.
No problem.
And problem is, your plan
doesn't survive past lunchtime
on Monday.
Something's going to come up.
Some new event is
going to come up
that requires a response
from the president or vice
president or both.
Some planned event will
be changed or dropped
from the schedule.
Something will be moved up on
the schedule, what have you.
So really, I mean, the
typical day, if there is one,
it's just making sure you're on
top of whatever speechwriting
assignments you
have at the time.
And usually, there's
pretty strict deadlines,
of course, on what
you're working on,
and pretty short time frames.
Writing a speech for the
president, in our experience
with George W. Bush, in general,
it was usually four to 10 days
to work on a speech.
The president gives
500 speeches a year,
so there's a lot going on.
And when the three of us,
Mike, Matthew, and myself
moved up from Austin, we kept
doing what we did in Austin.
But also Mike, who was
the chief speechwriter,
hired several other
writers to just fill
in the gaps in the remaining
amount of work that there was.
We still had editorial
responsibilities
for everything and
frontline responsibility
for all of the major addresses.
But we did have a larger team.
It was smaller than the
team that we replaced,
but still a good-sized team.
Six, seven writers at the
most, for president and vice
president.
A couple of researchers,
a couple of fact checkers.
So the speechwriting--
an event gets
put on the president's schedule.
OK, it's a major policy address.
He's going to be speaking
to the American Legion,
or he's going to be speaking
to the Chicago Economic Club,
or he's going to be speaking to
the Los Angeles World Affairs
Council or the Cedar Rapids,
Iowa, Chamber of Commerce,
or a Republican Party
dinner in Kentucky.
Just an endless, endless-- or a
town hall in Manhattan, Kansas.
There's just an
endless array of things
that the president
is going to do.
And so you get the assignment.
A writer is put on it.
If the core team was working
on it, we wrote together with--
literally at the same
computer, at the same screen,
with one keyboard in the same
room, starting with nothing,
and would work on
it on that basis.
The other writers on the
team didn't work that way.
They would do their draft and
then send it into Mike Gerson.
And then we would sit
down and go through it
and make sure it
had unity of voice
with the president's prior
speeches and the way he
liked things.
The policy people whose
main area of responsibility
was involved in the
speech, they would give us
the information that we needed.
I mean, they would say, OK.
The president's
giving a major speech
on social security policy.
We didn't have to think of what
the social security policy was.
Good thing, because we were
not experts in anything,
although my colleagues
were pretty sharp.
But we would get
the general policy,
and it was then our job to put
it in the president's voice
and to put it in a reasonably
economical and persuasive
speech that wasn't too
long, wasn't too detailed,
but also wasn't too simple.
All of the basic rules you want
to follow as speechwriters.
And then we would have
researchers kind of look
into background.
Where is the president speaking?
Is there something
about the place
that he is speaking that
will be of interest?
Now there will be some basics
that he's going to want
to know-- who he should
thank and acknowledge,
say something about
the place that--
the city he's in, what have you.
And then I believe we were the
first White House speechwriting
office that had this.
We had a fact-checking
division within speechwriting.
And they were so good that
other people in the White House
started using them.
And Mike Gerson
had to say, look.
This is not the White
House fact-checking office.
This is the White House
speechwriting department's
fact-checking division.
But they were very good,
and they kept us out
of a lot of trouble.
Because you know,
when you're just--
when you're churning
through these speeches,
I mean, you're
doing your very best
to be faithful to not just
the information that you have,
but the historical
references you
might be making
from your memory.
But the fact checkers would
always run these things down.
And then when the
draft was ready,
sometimes during the
fact-checking process,
it would be circulated
to the chief of staff
and then the department heads,
the senior White House staff.
And there would be a
cover page attached
to a copy of the
draft, cover page memo
from a person known as
the staff secretary.
So it was a very
important person
in the government of
the United States,
because she is the person who
controls the flow of paper
to the president and
from the president.
You want to give something
to the president,
you don't just wait till
you see him in the hallway
and slip it to him.
You have to give it to
the staff secretary.
And it's mainly, I think, for
efficiency, for record-keeping
purposes, for sure, and
because it's been done
that way for many, many years.
My understanding is that
going back to Eisenhower,
they've had this process
in the White House.
And it's literally
called staffing,
by which the whole purpose
is that when something gets
to the president, it has been
reviewed by the people who
need to review it so that the
president can have confidence
in it.
We wouldn't send a draft
speech to the president
that hadn't been fact checked.
We just wouldn't do it.
And I don't think the staff
secretary would let us,
because the staff
secretary would ask--
I'm thinking of Harriet
Miers, who was the staff
secretary at the beginning.
She would ask for the
annotated version.
You know, where's the
fact-checked version
of the speech?
Because if the president
has any questions,
we can only have
answers if we have--
whenever there's a verifiable
assertion in a speech,
it was the responsibility
of the fact checkers
to drop a footnote explaining
where that came from.
And so when the president
would get a speech,
he could be confident that, OK.
He never had to say, OK,
this is a major address
on foreign policy, for example.
The president never
had to say, well,
has this been reviewed by the
National Security Council?
The answer would
always be-- he didn't
have to ask that question.
Condi Rice would have
seen it, or her top deputy
would have seen it, and it
would have passed through them.
And they might
have made changes,
but the president didn't
have to know blow by blow
what happened in the process.
He just needed to know that
it went through the process.
And that's why if you ever had
a typo or anything, by the time
it reached the president,
a typo would have
gotten through a lot of people.
SPEAKER 1: Do you know if
that process continues today?
JOHN MCCONNELL: I'm
guessing it does.
I don't know exactly
what the speech process
is in the White House now.
I'd be interested in knowing,
but I just don't know.
But if I had to
guess, I would guess
that when a document
got to the president,
it had gone through staff.
It's just such an efficient
way of doing things.
One thing I remember
thinking when I
was learning about all these--
about these processes
and methods,
I thought, well, that
makes a lot of sense.
Let's suppose I read
something this weekend,
an article in "The New York
Times" magazine, or something
that I follow online,
and read it and found
it very interesting,
and just think,
well, I know the president
would be interested in this.
And if he didn't see it,
I'd like for him to see it.
Well, I would think, well, OK.
OK, I'll give this
to the president.
I'll give this to the
president's secretary,
and she'll give it to him.
Well, what if seven people
on the White House staff
had the same thought,
and all seven of them
gave this article to the
president's secretary
or somebody and said,
will you give this to him?
It's this pile of paper.
Or if you just give it
to the staff secretary,
the staff secretary might--
I'm guessing in a case like
that, if seven people said,
I'd like to make sure
the president saw this,
there's a memo to the president.
Attached is an article, and
the following seven people
suggested that you look at it.
So it's very streamlined
and everything else.
I also noticed at
the White House,
when you would get a document
back from the president,
it would be stamped.
They have a stamp that says,
the president has seen.
And that goes into
record-keeping.
So it's part of the
Presidential Records Act,
I'm sure, that if the
president has seen or had
something in his possession,
they need a record of that.
So it's all very,
very efficient.
Made our job easier
in a lot of ways,
because the staffing
process, you know,
they had to turn things
around pretty fast
and get them to
the speechwriters.
The cover memo
would say, comments
due in the speechwriting
office at 5:00 PM today.
They never had more
than a day or so.
They really didn't, because
we had to get that thing ready
and approved.
If it was a foreign trip
that the president was going
to be speaking on, we had to
get everything-- everything
he was going to say for those
week or 10 days prepared
and done and approved and in a
book before Air Force One took
off.
SPEAKER 1: What
was the difference
between writing
for the president
and writing for the
president when he
was a presidential candidate?
JOHN MCCONNELL: The
main difference was--
in the specific case
of George W. Bush,
I noticed that when I was first
working for him as governor,
and then as time went
on into his presidency
and into his second
term to the end,
he became a much
more active editor.
He was a pretty good
writer in his own right,
but not that he had a
heck of a lot of time
to sit down and write things.
But he never sort of let
up on the speechwriters
or the speechwriting process.
He never kind of laid off.
Even after years had
gone by, he still--
if anything, he was more
demanding as time went on,
because he got more
sure of himself
and how he wanted to
put things, and also
comfortable with the standards
that a president is entitled
to expect.
But if you speak in general
about the difference
between running for a president
and presidential candidate,
the main one is, of course,
the fact that in a campaign,
it's all about sharp contrast.
It's not just, vote for me.
It is, make sure not to
vote for my opponent.
And these can be
put in rough terms
or they can be put
in gentler terms,
and we've seen both
kinds, and we've seen much
in the range between the two.
Also in campaigns, you're
expressing aspirations.
You're expressing the hope that
you will be put in a position
to be able to do things.
You can say things like, I
will instruct the Secretary
of Veterans Affairs to carry
out a new policy of review
of the veterans' hospitals,
or whatever else.
And that's how you
write it in the speech.
But when you're writing
for the president, you say,
I have instructed the
Secretary of Veterans Affairs
to carry out this policy.
Suddenly you're doing things.
You have that power.
And the president can
speak for the nation
without any fear of
contradiction or seeming
presumptuous.
A candidate can't do that.
Campaigns are, by
their nature, divisive.
And so you've got
debates, you're
in a context where
ads are being run,
arguments are being
played out on TV.
Very high stakes
meetings between
the presidential candidates
and the pressure builds.
And as the election
draws near, the speeches
tend to get tougher, and
the definition of the choice
tends to get sharper.
And the expression of
feeling and intensity
of feeling about what's at stake
in this election, you know,
gets stronger.
And writing for a president,
again, the contrast,
it's much more about unity.
It's much more about appealing
to a far broader section,
not just of the country,
but of Congress.
I mean, you want everybody's
vote when you're running,
so it's not as if you're not
speaking to the whole country.
But by the same token,
when you're president,
you want to get things done.
It's not going to be quite so
much about the wrongheadedness
of your adversaries.
It's going to be if you're
going to be successful, I think.
You know, far greater
attempts to find common ground
and not be as divisive as
the rhetoric of a campaign.
SPEAKER 1: With regards
to national speeches,
how did you manage to be
able to connect with people
across all 50 states?
Because we have people that
have different backgrounds,
different needs.
How did you make that connection
in a way that was genuine?
JOHN MCCONNELL: That's
a very good question.
And I think that the answer
is, you just keep it at--
because of the
diversity you mentioned,
you just have to keep it
at a very general level.
You know, try to make the appeal
as broad as you possibly can.
Not that it's so general
as to be incoherent,
although politicians
have done that at times.
You hear them make a pitch,
and you have to think, well,
what exactly is
he talking about?
Or what exactly is he trying
to get people to agree to?
Sometimes the Italians
have a phrase, selling air.
[LAUGH]
And sometimes you hear that
in the political context.
But I always, when I
think in those terms,
I think about Ronald
Reagan, who always assumed
an intelligent listener.
And he assumed not necessarily
that the person was agreeing
with him, and not necessarily
that the person was disagreeing
with him, but that the
person was open-minded enough
to listen to him, and
therefore persuadable.
And so I always kept that
kind of ideal in front of me
when I was thinking
about an issue
that I had to write
persuasively on.
SPEAKER 1: And you were
at the White House right
in the middle of September 11.
What was that experience like?
JOHN MCCONNELL: Well, that was
the day everything changed,
of course, and we had just
gone through the first summer
of the presidency.
And it was kind
of a typical week.
The president was traveling.
The vice president was
at the White House.
And I remember my
colleague, Matthew Scully,
who I spent so much
time writing with
and write with now in
the private sector,
he and I spent all
of Monday, September
the 10th working on a speech for
the president for that Friday.
And I looked at my calendar
at the end of the day,
and I was getting
ready to go home.
And I thought, ooh.
The vice president has
a speech Friday too,
and I haven't really done
much thinking about that.
And I'd better check
with him about what
he would like to say.
So I called the vice
president's secretary
and asked if I could meet
with him the next morning
on the 11th.
And she told me to come in
first thing in the morning,
and I did.
And when I went to see him and
I was waiting outside his door--
he was finishing up a
brief meeting beforehand.
I got there about 8:30.
That's when I thought
I was going to see him.
Waited for a while, and
while I was waiting for him,
we received word
that the first plane
had hit the North Tower of the
World Trade Center in New York.
And while I was still waiting
for the vice president
and the TV was on and
we were looking at it,
that's when the Secret Service
man standing outside the door
got word that it was
a commercial jet that
had hit the World Trade Center.
And the instant
feeling in the room
was just this uneasy sense that
it probably wasn't an accident.
And then within a minute
or two, vice president
motioned me to come
into his office.
And I went into his
office, and the TV was on,
and it was, of course, on New
York and the burning tower.
And I just said,
oh, sir, I just want
to talk to you about
the speech for Friday.
And he said yeah, sit down.
But we really didn't talk.
We just sat there looking
at his television.
And while we were watching
it, the second plane
hit the South Tower.
And that was the moment that
it was obvious to everybody,
everybody watching, that
it was a coordinated attack
on the country.
And within a few minutes,
Condi Rice was in there.
Josh Bolten, the
Deputy Chief of Staff,
a couple other senior people.
And the vice president spoke
to the president on the phone
a couple times.
And I was in there, but no
one was looking over to me
asking for my advice
about what should be done.
And I told the story many times.
I thought, well,
whatever I was here
to talk to the vice
president about is not
going to be important anymore.
There's not going to be a speech
on Friday by the vice president
in any way connected with what I
was there to talk to him about.
So I left, and went
back to my office.
And this is the very
time that they discovered
that a plane was coming
at the White House
at 500 miles an hour.
And that's when the vice
president was evacuated
in a very intense scene,
a very rushed scene, where
he was taken down into a bunker,
which is somewhere under the 18
acres of the White House
complex, because the plane was
coming directly, almost
directly north at the White--
or I should say, east
at the White House.
And that's the one
that hit the Pentagon.
And if you look at
a map of Washington,
DC, the Pentagon and the White
House almost perfectly line up.
I always thought of the
Pentagon as being way, I guess,
east of the White House,
but it really isn't.
And if you've ever
flown into Washington
and you look for
the White House,
it's the last
thing you can find.
You can see the Capitol.
You can see the
Lincoln Memorial.
Washington Monument.
But the White House is
just really hard to find.
It's not the tallest
building in its neighborhood
by any stretch.
There's hotels nearby that are
taller than the White House.
You just can't find it, unless
you really know the city
and know where it is.
And so I don't know what
happened on that plane,
but maybe they just
couldn't find it,
and it hit the Pentagon.
I just don't know.
But anyway, it was coming
at the White House.
And that's when I called my
mom in northern Wisconsin
to reassure her that
everything was fine.
And she's the one who told me
to get out of the White House,
because she'd heard on
television that there
was an evacuation going on,
and I didn't know about it.
So I went out and
joined the evacuation.
And as I went out with
this throng of staff,
I remember one of the uniformed
Secret Service officers said,
everybody run.
There's a plane coming at us.
And I don't remember
running, but I
do remember seeing a
plane north of the White
House over 16th
Street, and thinking
that that was a plane that was
about to hit the White House
and destroy the White House
and kill everybody on board.
And I remember
that as the most--
you know, that was the most
genuinely shocking feeling that
I had had all day,
because I hadn't--
the evacuation,
I just, as I say,
just kind of found out about it.
There wasn't the moment
of shock other than seeing
that plane hit the South
Tower on TV, of course.
Was just seeing that
plane and being convinced,
I'm watching a plane that is
about to destroy the White
House.
It was not.
At that point, the Pentagon
had already been hit.
So what I saw was
either a military plane
or a commercial jet
that had been diverted.
I never found out what that was.
But people were wandering the
streets, White House staff.
And I thought, well,
I'm a speechwriter.
I'd better not go home.
They're probably going
to need some help
from the speechwriters today.
And I just-- there
was no evacuation plan
or anything else.
Nothing like this
had ever happened.
So I just remember
seeing another staff guy
on the street who worked in
the Office of Administration.
And he said, go to the
DaimlerChrysler headquarters
on I Street, because Mrs.
Bush's chief of staff's husband
worked over there
and just sent word,
if there's any White House staff
looking for a place to gather,
please come here.
And so that's where we
gathered, and I worked there
with Mike Gerson--
or I'm sorry, with
Matthew Scully
and a couple of our colleagues.
David Frum and Matt
Rees were there,
and we were on a speaker
phone with Mike Gerson.
And Mike had been driving
in to the White House,
and he was on Highway 395, going
in from Alexandria, Virginia,
toward the White House.
And he saw the plane
that hit the Pentagon.
He didn't witness
the impact, but he
saw the plane a moment
before, and never made it
into Washington.
They diverted all the traffic.
We did a draft speech for
the president for that night.
But really, that
project became the work
of Karen Hughes, his
senior counselor who
had been with them the whole
time that he was governor,
and had now moved to
Washington with them.
And really, the speech that
night was Karen's work.
And then right after that,
of course, Wednesday morning,
the 12th, we saw the President.
Mike and Matthew and I
were in there with him.
And of course, we
knew that we were
going to have some very
big assignments quite soon.
One of them was to write a
speech for a memorial service
at the National Cathedral, which
was going to be that Friday.
So that was a very
quick turnaround speech.
And that was where
Billy Graham preached,
and there were five presidents
of the United States
sitting in the front pew.
And then on Monday
morning, the 17th,
we got word that the
president was very likely
going to address Congress
on Thursday the 21st.
And that was the quickest
turnaround of a major address
we ever had.
That was a draft of a
speech to Congress, which
would be given to the largest
audience in human history,
and they wanted that
draft in one day.
And we did it.
We didn't have a conclusion,
but we drafted the speech.
But the president called
us in and gave us basically
the organization of
the speech by saying,
Americans have questions.
Who attacked our country?
Why do they hate us?
How do we fight and win
the war, and et cetera?
And that was pretty much
the organizing principle
of the speech, the questions
that Americans had.
SPEAKER 1: In general,
how did the president
prepare for his speeches?
JOHN MCCONNELL: President
Bush, he really prepared.
He would read things through.
He would make his edits.
And sometimes he
would call the writer
or he would give the edits
to the staff secretary,
and the staff secretary
would pass them along.
Or sometimes he would
call Mike Gerson,
and Mike would bring
them into the team.
But then when he
had the final draft,
if it was a major, major event
like the State of the Union,
which is the speech that
the speechwriters hate most,
because it's so huge and so
unwieldy, and it has so much--
it has to cover so many
bases that, you know,
you write 25 transitions
in one speech.
You usually have three
or four transitions.
But a speech like
that, you have to cover
so many different topics.
So that's a tough one.
Also the delivered draft of the
State of the Union is draft 30.
[LAUGH]
And so it's an endless process.
And it is also one
of about 20 speeches
the president gives in January.
So it's not like you have a
reprieve from everything else.
So to answer the question,
when the president would
have a State of
the Union, we would
do a heavy outline for
him around Christmas time,
and then he would react to it.
And the outline would
be based on the policy
input that had been generated
over the preceding few months.
OK, what's he going to
talk about in the State
of the Union?
What's going to be the program
for the year just begun?
And then we would sit down
and do the first draft.
And then that would go
through a very small--
a fraction of the
ordinary staffing process.
Just a few of the
very top people.
The vice president,
a few others.
And then you would go
for the second draft,
and then it would be a
slightly broader staffing.
And then you'd get
it to the president.
And then the president,
I remember he would--
that's when we would go
and sit in the Oval Office,
and he would sit
back in his chair
and read that speech aloud.
And throughout the State
of the Union process,
that's when I would see
the president the most,
more than any other speech.
In general, that's true,
because he would practice it.
There would be formal--
there's a movie theater in
the White House, about a third
of the width of this room,
about as deep, with curtains
and a movie screen and
movie theater seating,
and that's where he would
practice these big speeches.
And if you were
involved in the speech,
you were expected to be
there during the practice.
And so they'd set up the
lectern and the teleprompter,
and he would read things
through and edit there.
So that was a very
elaborate, involved process.
He did the same thing with the
address to Congress after 9/11.
It just was very
telescoped, right?
It all happened within a
space of two or three days.
And then for the
typical speech, he
didn't use a teleprompter
probably more than 10 times
a year.
President Obama used it,
I mean, 10 times a week.
And he just-- and Reagan
used it a lot more
than George W. Bush did.
But if it was a
non-teleprompter event,
which is the typical case,
he would read it aloud.
He would underline things.
He would practice it.
He would edit up
until the very end.
Not edit in the
sense that he would
call the speechwriter
if he wanted
one word changed on page four.
You know, sometimes
he would just
scribble that in or make
a couple notes to himself
at the top.
But I always--
I have told people,
people I have worked
for who do public speaking
in the private sector
now, in some cases, don't
think they're very good at it.
And I often remind them that
not everybody's good at it,
but you can be if
you work at it.
And I always say, the
president got better
at it over his career,
I think he would say.
I certainly would say it.
Because he practiced.
He wanted it to sound good.
We would read our speeches aloud
before we sent them into him,
because you never know--
you can think you know
how it's going to sound,
but you don't until you hear it.
And so we would.
We would read these
things aloud to make sure
it had the right rhythms, that
some words are not good speech
words, and so you
want to keep them out.
But sometimes writers
let them slip in.
And you know, you
just get a feel for--
you know, you don't
want something to rhyme.
[LAUGH]
And I remember we
discovered that once
in one of our read-throughs.
Something rhymed.
And that was-- we
didn't want that.
[LAUGH]
And then in the president's
case, the vice president too,
the vice president wore glasses.
President wore
glasses sometimes,
but not when he was
giving speeches.
And so the speeches
were in big type,
so he could read it
without his glasses.
And I will just say that
I talked to a guy who
worked for Ronald Reagan.
Actually, I met the guy, but
he didn't tell me this story.
The story came to me
secondhand that he
was with Reagan on his
campaign plane in 1980,
and he said that Reagan
was going over a speech
very carefully on the
way to the next city.
And Reagan didn't-- and the
guy tried to interrupt Reagan,
and Reagan was kind of annoyed,
and kind of held him off.
Not now.
And his initial thought was,
he gives this speech four times
a day.
Why does he need to sit here
and over this and practice?
And he realized that Reagan
really wanted the next one
to be great.
Even if he was reading
the same speech,
he wanted it to
be a great event,
so he needed to get
into the moment.
And so that's another thing
I would remind people.
There's no such thing
as overpreparing.
There is such thing
as overediting.
We've all seen that,
when a document is just--
I remember Karen
Hughes said about one
of the State of the
Union drafts we had done.
This particular year we had
done it a little bit earlier,
earlier than was customary.
And by the time
the event came, I
remember there were people
editing their own edits,
making suggestions,
language changes on things
they had forgotten they
had changed themselves.
And Karen Hughes
said, this thing's
been floating around
a little too long.
And so you have to avoid that.
Overediting is a
real phenomenon,
because you run into people who
think new is better than good,
and that is not always the case.
But it feels fresh because it's
new, and that can be dangerous.
But overpreparing in terms
of getting up and reading
a speech, I don't
think I can think of--
I don't think I can imagine
an example of someone
overpreparing.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah,
that's really helpful.
Because I think
even here at Google,
there's a lot of opportunities
where public speaking can
be relevant, whether it's giving
a presentation to your team
or speaking at
the I/O conference
that we just had last week.
So with regards
to overpreparing,
do you think that it's better to
sort of just write a few notes
and then improvise the
rest of your speech,
or have a full
speech written out
and then try to go from there?
JOHN MCCONNELL: It
can be done both ways.
I've done it both ways myself.
The first question you
need to ask yourself
is, how long am I
expected to speak?
That is a big variable.
If they just say, you're
going to get an hour of time,
and you can come in and talk
about whatever you want,
everyone's excited
to hear what you
have to say about anything
that's on your mind,
those are the greatest events--
[LAUGH]
--because you're ready now.
But on the assumption
that those are rare,
if you have five
minutes, my advice
is, write out every
word you want to say.
Do the word count, and
if it's at 750 words,
you cannot go any
longer than that.
The 750 words, if you can get
that in the five-minute window,
you know, you're speaking
150 words a minute,
that's pretty fast.
You should aim for 100 to
120, something like that.
It's hard to predict,
because you don't know--
there's variables such
as audience reaction.
You know, how fast
someone speaks
and other individual
factors like that.
But the important thing is if
it's a small window of time--
I had a private sector client
come to me a few years ago
and my colleague, Matthew.
This guy just couldn't
get his message across
in less than 45 minutes.
But he wanted to.
And he wanted-- but he
liked to speak from notes,
and he realized that he
could never speak from notes
and come in, clock
in under 45 minutes.
And so they sent us
videos and transcripts
of some of his
45-minute speeches.
And our assignment was,
write a 20-minute speech
that makes all these points.
And so we did.
And then our only advice
to the guy was, read this.
Get comfortable with it.
Get so comfortable with it that
you've almost got it memorized.
But keep it in front
of you, because that's
a position of real
comfort on the platform
is when you've got it in
front of you, every word,
but you don't have
to look at it.
Because you don't have to
be nervous about forgetting,
about something
throwing you off,
which has happened
to people who've
tried to memorize speeches,
and it just kind of fell apart.
But just get really
conversant and comfortable
with that speech,
and have it with you.
And people will
be very impressed,
because you will have a
very economical and polished
presentation that comes in
within the window that's
given you.
Now that's the extreme case.
And speaking from notes is
always very good, as long
as you are very comfortable
with the timing.
I remember, one of
my great friends
I got to know just
through this work,
his name was George Elsey.
And I looked him up when I
moved to Washington in 2000.
And George had been a military
aide to President Franklin
Roosevelt during
the war, and then he
was a speechwriter for President
Truman his whole presidency.
Traveled around the
country with Truman.
And he just was a wise old
gentleman and wonderful
to talk to.
And he died at age 98 about
a year and a half ago.
There have been a
lot of speechwriters
who have [INAUDIBLE] a long
time, I'm happy to say.
[LAUGH]
But I was going to give a
speech to a group of cadets
at a military school.
And I knew what I
wanted to talk about.
I had a little history
I wanted to talk about,
and I wanted to relate
it to their experience.
And I really-- I was
going to speak from notes,
and I had 10 minutes.
And this was about-- it
was about 10 years ago.
I called George,
and I said, George.
You're just going to love this.
I want to tell you about a
speech I'm going to give.
And he said, OK.
And so I said--
I didn't give him the speech.
I read through my notes.
I said, I'm going to talk
about this a little bit,
then I'm going to
say thus and so.
So I didn't give him the
speech, but just gave him
the map of what I was
going to be talking about.
And he listened.
Mhm, mhm.
He didn't interrupt.
And I got to the end of it.
And he said, oh,
that's all very good.
That's all very good.
He said, you know the
trouble, don't you?
And I said, what?
He said, you've got material
there for two speeches,
and they've asked
you to give one.
[LAUGH]
And I said, really?
He said, you've got
two right there.
And I started going through
it, and he was right.
He was right.
When I sort of
looked at my notes,
OK, now I'm going to talk
about, now I'm going to--
now I'm going to just sit here
with my notes in the quiet
of my office and kind
of look over at the wall
and at my notes, and pretend
I'm giving this speech.
It really went on 50% too long.
So that's when I had
to ruthlessly cut.
So it's OK to speak from notes,
but it's really important
to know precisely how
you're going to start,
precisely how
you're going to end,
and then how you're
going to fill the time.
I always say as well that even
with experienced speakers,
sometimes they lose
track of the time.
And-- not completely lose track,
but eight minutes in, and they
realize they've only got two
minutes left instead of their--
you know, they're just farther
along in their window of time
than they thought they were.
You can save yourself by
just knowing in advance
how this thing ends.
Because you can
always race to your--
you can always race
to your conclusion.
And you can say, I didn't
get to cover this last point
as much as I would like.
If some would like me to
elaborate during the Q&A,
I'd be happy to.
But I really want to
close on this thought.
And then you're home free.
The most painful ones
to see are the ones
who don't know how
they're going to end.
And so you can feel them
circling the target.
But they just don't know where.
[LAUGH]
They don't know where
to drop the munition.
SPEAKER 1: And on
that note, I'm going
to get to my last question
before our Q&A session--
[LAUGHTER]
--which is, what do you
think about Trump's speeches?
JOHN MCCONNELL: I was
interested to watch
Trump develop as a speaker
during the campaign.
It was-- I'm quite
certain this is
the only campaign, definitely
in the television age,
where you could get
basically every network that
was broadcasting news live
go with that candidate,
knowing in advance that
that candidate didn't
have a speech in front of him.
It was just him.
And he spoke from notes.
And he started, toward the
end of the campaign, I guess,
reading speeches.
But he sure didn't
do that very much.
And I was really struck during
the campaign at how far--
I mean, he got all the
way to the nomination,
basically, without
reading speeches.
Nobody has done that in
our lifetimes until him.
And now, of course, he's
reading a lot more speeches.
And as I said before, I don't
know what the process is.
But whatever it is,
it works for them.
And the speech to
Congress, I thought
he sounded very much
like a president.
There was so much
commentary beforehand.
What's this going to be like?
Is he going to come in
and pull some notes out?
Throw it on the rostrum
with the assembled
Congress of the United States
and the Supreme Court sitting
there, the diplomatic corps,
the Joint Chiefs of Staff,
the whole nation watching.
But no.
He didn't.
He did not treat that casually.
He sounded like a president.
But I used to love to-- when I
would sit down with my friend
George Elsey who had
written for Truman,
all he wanted to talk
about was what I was doing.
And my interest was in pulling
information from him about what
happened in the 1940s.
And I said, George,
all you want to talk
about's the 43rd president.
All I want to talk about
is the 33rd president.
SPEAKER 1: Well,
thank you so much.
So now we can go
into our Q&A session.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Thanks for coming.
Any advice on ums and ahs?
And also, if you detect you're
starting to lose your audience
or something like that,
you see eyes glazing over,
any way to, you know,
re-navigate on the fly
while giving a speech?
JOHN MCCONNELL: Um, OK.
There was your um.
[LAUGHTER]
You just have-- you really have
to not become self-conscious.
Just be yourself.
It's going to happen when
you're speaking from notes just
off the cuff.
You have to listen to yourself.
I remember reading that
Richard Nixon did not ever
watch himself on TV, because
he was afraid of becoming
self-conscious.
And this happens.
This happens to people.
But on the other hand, I have
to guess that John Kennedy did
watch himself.
And this was a
person who, really
at the dawn of the
television age,
became very, very adept at that.
I would like to know--
I would be interested in knowing
what other presidents did,
what other successful candidates
for lesser offices did.
Reagan, there was a story
somewhere about Reagan.
He was in the Oval Office,
and he was so comfortable
with cameras, right?
He'd been a movie actor for
30 years and a broadcaster,
and had also done live
TV in his 40s, which
was a pretty fairly new venue.
When Ronald Reagan
was 40 years old,
live TV was just
really hitting it.
Anyway, Reagan is preparing to
give a speech to the nation,
and there's a monitor.
And he always-- the
monitor was facing him
so that he could see
what the camera saw.
And he would glance over at it.
He wouldn't look at it during
his speech, but he would--
this was part of
his preparation.
The monitor would come on.
He knew he was about to go
live, and he was prepared.
And the story was that
he was at his desk
and he's got his speech,
and the lights are on
and he's looking at the camera.
He's familiar.
But he's looking
over at the monitor.
There's nothing on there.
And he's just kind
of looking over.
The monitor's black.
Nothing.
The time is ticking away.
Finally, it comes on, and Reagan
sees himself on the monitor
live.
And he goes, oh, there he is.
[LAUGHTER]
You have to--
there's nothing wrong
with being sort of aware of
how you look and how you sound.
I think this is how the
best-- and Reagan was one
of the best--
become good.
So if a person is really, really
concerned about verbal tics
or whatever, I guess
the advice I would give
would be to watch
themselves some more.
And then the second
part of your question
about losing an
audience, there are
many ways for people to do it.
But really, even the
most polished speaker
is going to lose their
audience after about 20 minutes
of a speech.
Even your best friends
are going to start to go,
when is this going to end?
You really don't need to
take it that much longer.
You know, that is
a prepared speech.
Unless you have--
unless it's so obvious
you have so much
ground to cover.
But to pull people
back, humor is always
the best way to do it.
But that has to be
something very--
something very genuine
and something--
timing is everything.
It's hard to give
advice in the abstract,
but the best advice
is just end the thing.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: I expect that
many Americans don't
watch all speeches
in their entirety,
but rather will see some
portions of the speech
as highlighted by the media.
And as a speechwriter,
how does one
identify what those
hits will be as opposed
to the entire album in advance?
Like, focusing on areas.
JOHN MCCONNELL: Yeah,
that's hard to do.
I can't tell you
how many times when
we were writing
these speeches, we
would put something
together and think, OK,
now that is going to be the
signature line of this speech,
and get it wrong.
Just wouldn't happen.
Difficult to predict.
Sometimes you can nail it,
just know that something
is going to get attention.
And unfortunately, in
today's political culture,
if it's something with
kind of a hard edge,
if it's something that is
making fun of an adversary
or something-- you know, if
it just is kind of personal
and is interpreted by the media
as an attack requiring a reply,
it will always be picked up.
But you know, in my case, I
worked for President Bush.
He didn't want to do too
much of that kind of thing.
So it's hard to do.
You keep striving for it,
but it's hard to predict.
I always felt like the
reporters, sometimes
they would have their
story half written
before the speech was
done, because they would
be given the speech in advance.
And sometimes you need to
hear it in order to realize,
what were the lines that
had the best impact?
And what were the lines that
really drove the argument home?
Or just reading it
real quickly to see--
very often, they would
put into the stories more
of the fact-specific
stuff than the stuff
that we thought was really
appealing and musical,
and were sure would
be appreciated
for the beauty of
its composition.
[LAUGH]
Hard to predict, I have to say.
But you're always
striving for it.
AUDIENCE: How do you approach
keeping a consistent message
when the target is changing or
when expectations don't live up
to what you had initially said?
So I'm going to sell
something for $40.
I'm going to sell it for $40.
Well, actually, it's
going to cost $60,
and that information
comes later.
As a speechwriter,
how do you craft--
how do you shape the narrative?
[SIGH]
JOHN MCCONNELL: Always--
the general point
there would be always allow
yourself the possibility
that the facts on the
ground are going to change.
You know, if your sales pitch
is going to need to change,
then there may be something
that needs refining
in what it is you're selling.
But in general, if
you know that you're
in a situation that's
subject to change,
through no fault of your own
and through no dishonesty
of your own, you just
have to allow yourself--
allow for the fact that
there could be changes.
Don't predict.
When we worked for President
Bush, I mean, it was a rule.
Don't brag on the stock market.
Wow, the stock market went up.
If the president
brags on that, it
sounds like he's
taking credit for it.
And if the stock market goes
down, then what do you do?
Then what do you do?
I don't think that that rule
has been consistently applied,
but in our case, it
was just something
we were told not to
do, and never did.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
JOHN MCCONNELL: You bet.
SPEAKER 1: OK, I do have a
question from [INAUDIBLE] now.
This question is from Tim.
If tasked with writing
a speech for President
Trump or a character with a
similar off-the-cuff style,
how would you approach the task?
How might this differ depending
on the speech, such as State
of the Union or charity event?
JOHN MCCONNELL: Well,
everything hinges
on the nature of the speech.
The first question I always
have in connection with a speech
assignment, other than
the obvious information
of who's speaking and
what the general subject
matter is, the first question
I ask is, who is the audience?
Is it your friends?
Is it the unpersuaded?
Is it your adversaries?
Is the press there?
In most cases, it will be.
Is it a political event?
Is it a nonpartisan event?
I mean, really
nonpartisan, like a chamber
of commerce or something?
Is it a building dedication?
Is it a funeral?
Is it-- just, is
it a commencement?
All these things.
I always feel like
I'm halfway there
if I know precisely the
nature of the audience.
And so that's the first
question I would ask.
And if you're
writing for someone
who does a lot of
off-the-cuff, I mean,
give him some space to do that.
President Bush,
we gave him space
to do that at the
beginning of the speech.
He liked to do off-the-cuff
acknowledgements and things
like that.
And then talk to him.
The best connections between--
the most successful
speechwriting stories
involve, in my experience,
a real connection
between the writer and the
person he's writing for.
If you just get to know
him and can get to him
and can talk to him-- you don't
have to be his best friend.
You don't have to be in
his office all the time.
But they've got to
know the writers.
They've got to have
some sort of connection.
Because writers,
if they're not too
wrapped up in their own
artistry or whatever,
your whole job is to learn.
And I would also say,
I've had this conversation
with my former colleague,
Matthew Scully.
One of the great
satisfactions of the process I
described earlier, the three
writers working together,
was the satisfaction of
producing something really good
as part of a team.
It was even better
than the satisfaction
of producing something
really good on your own,
because you're working
with people you like
and people you trust.
And you find that you
are upholding together
a standard of performance
and effectiveness
that you always want
to uphold on your own,
but always feel good
as well when it's
part of a common enterprise.
And so although most writers
don't like the idea of writing
as part of a group-- most
writers like to write
in solitude--
I just found that it brought
one of the great satisfactions
of my career, being
part of a team that
had a shared standard of
excellence and performance
and pride in the
common enterprise.
And that builds friendships
and long-term associations.
AUDIENCE: The show "West Wing"
glamorized speechwriting,
in a sense.
I don't know if you
ever watched the show.
But there are certain
characters who
seem to have a passion
for it, even including
things like the choice
of words and passages.
Is this something that you
feel is an innate thing?
Can it be learned?
I mean, if you're good at
it, can you become great?
If you're average,
can you become great?
You know, can you say a
little bit more about--
I mean, it seems to be
an art to this thing.
JOHN MCCONNELL: Yeah.
I do think that it is at
one level kind of a knack.
I mean, that is, there
are people who just
have a natural gift in writing.
And I know them and look up to
them, admire them very much.
It's also a tool you can
sharpen, no question.
I think you become a
better writer by writing.
You become a better
writer by rewriting.
That I know.
You become a better
writer by reading.
I really think that one of
the greatest things you can do
is just--
is just be an omnivorous reader.
Because you're going to
be drawn to good writing
if it's something that
interests you and it's something
in an area that you
want to know more about,
an area that's just
part of your life.
It doesn't matter
what the subject is.
It just matters that you keep
developing your sense of what
good writing is
just by seeing it,
getting to know the quality.
I find that even now, when
I listen to speeches on TV,
which I always have
done my whole life,
I'm really struck at
how many times you just
hear cliches being repeated
in set-piece speeches.
Everybody spouts cliches in
conversation, because so much
of what we say is just
what's just come to our mind.
But writing is supposed
to be something different.
It's thinking.
It's thinking things through.
It's thinking things from
the perspective of not just,
how does this appeal to someone
who likes what I'm saying,
but how is this going
to sound to someone
who dislikes what I'm saying?
And I just--
I find that when I hear
strings of cliches,
it sounds to me like someone
was given the task of writing
something, but really didn't put
any thought or effort into it.
I always quote David
McCullough, who
said, writing is thinking
and thinking is hard.
But it pays off.
And just not necessarily
calling attention
to the writing itself,
but it pays off
when it really calls
attention to the point that
is being made, and
the writing is good
and it is conversational.
It's unpretentious.
And therefore, the
listener likes it.
But the listener isn't really
thinking about the writing.
The listener is really thinking
about the point being made.
That's when you've
got something.
SPEAKER 1: It looks like maybe
we have time for just one
more question.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So President Bush
speaks Spanish.
Various presidents
have had faculties
with other languages
besides English in the past,
like Kennedy including German
in his speech in Berlin.
At what point does
a speechwriter
include or think about
delivering a speech
in a different language?
Or what are the strategic
considerations in including
other languages in speeches?
JOHN MCCONNELL: Well,
make sure it's right.
I remember poor Hillary
Clinton with that reset button.
I forget what it meant,
but it didn't mean reset.
And that's just-- that's the
writer's nightmare, right?
OK.
This is-- I know
what this means.
There's an old story that
Berliner is actually the word
meaning pastry or something.
[LAUGH]
And then so that technically,
President Kennedy said,
I am a pastry, or I'm a
jelly donut, or something.
And I was at a dinner of former
White House speechwriters
a few years ago
with Ted Sorensen,
who I got to know just
through this organization
of former White
House speechwriters.
And he spoke to that directly.
He said, you know,
there's a weekly magazine
called "The New Yorker."
He said, if I stood up and
said, I am a New Yorker,
no one would interpret me as
saying, I am a weekly magazine.
He said, everybody knew what
President Kennedy was saying,
and it's kind of a cheap shot,
you know, years after the fact.
But I mean-- and you've got
to get the pronunciation down,
and everything else.
I remember when I worked
for Vice President Quayle.
He went to Lithuania right
after Lithuania was no longer
part of the Soviet Union.
And he said some
things in Lithuanian.
But I remember, we really
went over those and made sure.
We wanted it to
sound right, and we
wanted to make sure it meant
what it was supposed to mean.
SPEAKER 1: Great.
Well, thank you
so much, everyone,
for coming and for tuning in.
It was great to have you.
[APPLAUSE]